السياسة المحافظة مع العالم التركي
كما أنها تأخذ العالم الإسلامي كأساس.
[موسيقى]
السيد الرئيس أردوغان المحترم
وكذلك القومية
لديه موقف محافظ ، السيد سنان
أوغان
هذا هو الآخر ، حيث أن ميلييت مثالية
أحد الأشخاص الذين تم التعرف عليهم من الأصدقاء
القومية لها موقف مثالي
على سبيل المثال ، الشعب الجمهوري
نفس قومية الحزب
هناك موقف كمالي في نفس الوقت.
كمفهوم مشترك القومية ولكن
ها هي قومية السيد أردوغان
السيد الثاني سنان أوغان أو نفسه
دعنا نحدد
قومية البطريرك
فارق بسيط بين القومية
هناك اختلافات صغيرة حتى التفاصيل
ما هو موجود ، على سبيل المثال ، في واحد
وكذلك مفهوم الأمة
هذه هي الأمة في السياسة المحافظة
كما أنه يقوم بشيء ما دون تجاهل
على جانب واحد
الكمالية هي نفس الحساسية.
في نفس الوقت ، هل هذه علمانية بلا استحقاق؟
يمكن إضافة دقة قدمها سنان
أوغان وأسماء مماثلة
هنا مفهوم يعتمد على التاريخ التركي
لكن الموقف المشترك هو وطن
جغرافيا جمهورية تركيا
حماية حدود دولته و
ما وراء الحدود هو نفسه في المناطق النائية
للتسليم في الوقت المحدد
هي القومية في القومية التركية
يغلب على القوميين الأتراك.
محافظ
سياسة الإسلام مع العالم التركي
أيضا على أساس العالم الثالث العلمانية
أيضا في الهياكل العلمانية القائمة عند نقطة
توثيق العلاقات مع العالم الغربي
إنها قومية داعية ، لكنها قومية
كما قلنا في هذه النقطة ، تركيا
نقطة الدفاع عن حدود الجمهورية
لديه